le graffiti est devenu un art
incontournable aux vertus parfois
originales la commune de plaisir l'a
bien compris le quartier du valibou en
plein chantier de réhabilitation va
participer à un projet inédit dans la
région des artistes de cité création
vont recouvrir les façades de fresques
inspiré des scènes de vie ça c'est déjà
fait à chartre et près de Lyon résultat
les œuvres réduisent les dégradations et
attirent même les touristes place à la
musique maintenant le premier contest
européen de beatbox s'est déroulé à
Saint-Germain en lait regardez ou plutôt
écouez dimanche à Saint-Germain en lait
l'équipe de France est en finale au
terme d'une compétition de 3 jours h
équipes national se sont affrontés pour
le tout premier titre européen de
l'histoire du beatbox car il ne s'agit
pas ici de sport mais de
[Musique]
musique
après avoir vaincu sous forme de Battle
musical la Russie et l'Espagne les
quatre membres de l'équipe de France se
prépare pour la grande finale puisque la
compète est à la fois en solo en équipe
on a chacun nos boîtes secrètes en en
solo et voilà et pour l'équipe on a on a
vraiment mis en place toutes nos idées
et on a tous notre spécialité en solo
après en équipe bah on essaie de
rassembler un peu nos forces voilà et
puis voilà la technique de toute façon
la France c'est la technique la
France la technique et puis la diversité
des le flot et le flot le Grou le
grouove le flot tout le hip
[Musique]
hop
[Rires]
[Musique]
cette discipline musicale qui consiste à
interpréter vocalement des sons et des
rythmes a pris ses sources dans le scat
jazzman puis s développé avec le hiphop
je suis impressionné
par le niveau par les performances et
aussi par l'évolution qu'il a eu par
rapport en fait au Big boxing parce
qu'avant c'était la reproduction des
instruments qui avaiit comme la batterie
comme la guitare comme le scratch et
puis au fur à mesure ils ont se sont
appropriés tous les styles comme
l'électro comme le dub comme tout ça
donc c'est on a un panel qui est
vraiment
[Musique]
important sur le podium du premier
championnat européen de beatbox
l'Allemagne imposé la France est
[Musique]
deè dans un tout autre registre brille
Terry Bible l'artiste guant Courtois est
ISS de la scne
[Musique]
portraitile
d'iminerant c'est la musique à la flu
traversière aujourd'hui le Guillon
Courtois est riche d'influences varié
j'ai essayé de mélanger par rapport à
mes influences musicales par exemple le
hip hop ou encore l'électro aussi du
coup on a essayé de mélanger notre
musique on avait un concept de musique
dite urbaine j'ai voulu changer ce
concept là en disant qu'on fait de la
Hope music donc c'est plus de la musique
qui est avec nos propos qui sont
fédérateurs et qui ont des des valeurs
d'espoir et d'unité un rassemblement
mais pas le même qu'on pourrait penser
mais un rassemblement des cœurs et des
[Musique]
cons des paroles au vibration positives
que l'on retrouve sur une mix de 14
morceaux disponible sur le site de
l'tiste
figure internationale de laène de
passage à la batterie de gu encour
l'occasion Rê pour dévoiler lors de ce
live une partie de son
dernierici l'été j'ai mon album mon
prochain album qui va sortir qui
s'appelle donc large
em on y arriver on ira plus
[Applaudissements]
haut
cette fois-ci direction Versailles où
les jeunes ont pu s'inicier un atelier
de DJ lors du premier festival des arts
[Musique]
urbains initiation au DJing l'art d'être
DJ à la maison de quartier jucieux à
Versailles avec au platine 1
professionnel aujourd'hui pas de Viny
mais une tablette numérique pour
diffuser les morceaux après avoir
appréhendé le matériel les jeunes
versaillais se
[Musique]
lanent ce que je leur apprends
aujourd'hui c'est le Baby scratch donc
le scratch bébé le ciseau il y a le
transformer aussi et puis je rapprends
un peu de flair ou de crab il y a toutes
sortes de figures comme à l'instar des
gammes en guitare aujourd'hui le scratch
s'écrit sur des
partitions c'est difficile parce qu'il
faut bien faire avec les doigts et ça en
même temps etil c'est difficile il faut
avoir le ryth savoir faire en fait cet
atelier s'inscrit dans le cadre du
premier festival des arts urbains
organisé cet été dans toutes les maisons
de quartier de Versailles c'est une
culture qui est pas vraiment diffusée
dans cette ville et du coup on a vu
qu'il y avait quand même un gros
collectif qui s'est fait dans versaill
autour de bah du Hipop c'est un peu un
challenge euh oui oui oui complètement
parce que c'est ça va à l'encontre un
peu de de l'image de la ville le hiphop
prend ainsi ses marques petit à petit
dans la cité royale une école de DJ a
même ouvert il y a quelques mois avis
aux amateurs de tout âge et tout
niveau si vous avez entre 11 et 17 ans
et que vous souhaitez vous aussi vous
initiez aux cultures urbaines le Conseil
général a concocté tout un programme le
point sur le dispositif Eveline
campus bonjour Alexandre jolie quel a
été votre rôle dans l'élaboration du
planning Eveline campus c'est tout
d'abord une volonté politique du
président Alan Schmid et de l'ensemble
de l'équipe et ce depuis maintenant
plusieurs années depuis les états
généraux de la jeunesse en particulier
en 2006 où est venu d'où est venue cette
idée de d'ivline campus alors pour cette
édition 2013 on trouve des des activités
dites atypiques oui c'est ça
etchass woman beatbox vous savez ce que
c'est ça saviez avant oui oui parce
qu'il y avait une chanteuse qui le qui
le faisait en début d'un de ces de ces
morceaux et qui est devenu un tube où
elle fait des bruits avec la bouche et
elle elle imite un certain nombre de de
choses et ça devient j'allais dire la
bouche devient presque une boîte à à
rythmique instrument et vous-même vous
aimeriez participer à un type d'activité
proposé alors j'avoue que sur l'ensemble
des
activités les peut-être les les échasses
parce que j'ai en pension à Versailles
c'était le jeu préféré de la cour de
récréation déjà à l'époque donc c'est
peut-être là où je me sentirai plus à
l'aise et proposer des loisirs urbains
est-ce que ça fait partie d'une mode
d'une tendance bah surtout ça ça
correspond à ce que les jeunes attendent
si on veut qu'il passe un moment
agréable tout en découvrant d'autres
personnes qui sont de d'autres quartiers
de d'autres villes il faut effectivement
que ça soit attractif et c'est un le but
rechercher tout à l'heure je vous
parlais des états généraux de
l'adolescence c'est ce qui a permis un
petit peu de savoir quelles étaient leur
leurs attentes et quel est le type
d'ambiance qu'on retrouve sur ces
ateliers ce sont des professionnel qui
anime l'ensemble des des ateliers et
puis c'est un moment de de partage un
moment de découverte je crois que c'est
un moment exceptionnel pour pour ces
jeunes ça leur permet dans dans cette
ambiance d'abord d'avoir une une estime
de soi quand ils sont timides ou pas
très sûr d'eux ça leur donne aussi
l'envie d'entreprendre parce que c'est
intéressant et je je crois que certains
d'entre eux même parfois arrivent à à à
à rêver de passer un BAFA ou d'être à
leur tour animateur ou deou de pouvoir
réaliser dans leur quartier quelque
chose qu'ils ont découvert lors de ces
Vline campus et peut-être susciter des
vocations pour des futurs grands
graffeurs ou danseurs hiph-hop en plus
effectivement effectivement c'est ce que
j'appelais le donner l'envie
d'entreprendre et combien ça coûte assz
pour les jeunes c'est gratuit et pour le
Conseil général 560000 € c'est un eff
important ensemble de l'année pour
l'ensemble des des quatre lieux où se
passent les campus c'est les aras des
brevières maison la fite m la jolie
l'île l'umôe et versaill porche fontaine
un dernier petit mot pour donner envie
aux jeunes de de venir rejoindre le
dispositif je crois regardez le site du
Conseil Général renseignez-vous vous
allez vraiment passer un moment
extraordinaire merci beaucoup je vous en
[Musique]
prie on ne peut pas parler de cultures
urbaines sans évoquer les battles de
break dance retour sur le hip hop Games
concept qui s'est tenu à 5tin en
illine ça pulsait sur la scène du
pavillon Val des crousseau à guilloncour
en piste quatre équipes pour SEP
épreuvees face à un jury d'experts du
challenge du partage et du plaisir
c'était le but de ces danses
d'improvisation de Hipop Games concept
organisé pour la première fois dans le
cadre du festival pulsation
[Musique]
urbaine pour moi le hiphop game concept
c'est un trait d'union entre le battle
et la scène c'est tout ce qui se passe
pour fabriquer une création hip hop
c'est-à-dire danser avec des contraintes
des accessoires
contre avec d'autres personnes voilà
c'est tout ça qui fait que on est dans
un système de jeu l'un après l'autre les
danseurs se joue de l'improvisation et
démontrre leur talent sur les bancs les
autres participants encouragent admirent
en attendant leur
[Musique]
tour
sur scène les danses s'enchaînent en
rythme ou plus
lente à l'honneur la technique la
théâtralité et l'écoute ce jour-là
l'équipe gagnante voyait son projet de
création accompagné et diffusé par les
partenaires du
territoire la création artistique autour
du hiph hop évolue sous l'influence
d'autres danses la compagnie diradia en
a fait l'expérience lors de son année en
résidence d'artiste dans un collège de
trappe performance de danseur
professionnel au collège yri Gagarine de
trappe c'est la compagnie d'ifradia qui
fête la fin de sa résidence d'artiste
dans l'établissement cette année
certains collégiens volontaires ont
participé à des ateliers expérimentaux
ils dévoilaient ce jour leurs talent à
leurs
camarades
les artistes en fait ont vraiment adapté
le niveau proposé de technique de danse
aux élèves débutants donc quel que soit
le niveau de la 6e à la 3e les contenus
ont toujours été adaptés pour que tout
le monde soit en réussite
l'établissement scolaire va ainsi plus
loin dans l'ouverture culturelle de ses
élèves pour leur plus grand bonheur pour
moi la danse est un peu un moyen de
m'exprimer de me défouler quand je danse
c'est comme si je volis en fait je sais
pas tous mes problèmes il s'envolent
comme ça et popping break dance et Crump
n'ont plus de secret pour les jeunes
mais la présence des danseurs
professionnels pendant un an avait
d'autres
ambitions modifier les représentations
qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui de la danse
urbaine puisque c'est la danse Hipop est
une danse qui a 30 ans un petit peu plus
de 30 ans et c'est une danse qui a
beaucoup évolué aussi dans ses formes on
est parfois dans des représentations qui
ne correspondent plus vraiment à ce que
les créateurs proposent et aussi ce
temps où les artistes viennent dire mais
le corps c'est pas rien le corps
qu'estce qu'on peut en faire pour
justement faciliter les apprentissages
scolaires ce travail du rapport à soi et
à l'autre la découverte de la mixité de
l'esprit collectif ou encore du partage
de l'espace améliorerait le climat en
classe et que pense les artistes de
cette expérience au collège à la fois ça
nourrit ma ma réflexion ça m'a également
remis en question et oui oui c'était
très bonifiant ça m'a donné envie
d'approfondir en fait ma démarche en
tant en tant qu'artiste et d'où cette
nécessité d'être au plus
près des gens et de partager et
d'échanger le projet issu de ce cours
mélange les gens et les genres hip hop
jazz danse contemporaine et africaine
pour décrire l'enfermement social et
faire passer ce message les identités se
construisent dans l'altérité le rêve et
la
[Musique]
liberté
I